hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
while president-elect joe biden
continues to move ahead with his
transition plans
republicans are shifting their attention
to two runoff elections in georgia
where the outcome will determine which
party controls the senate
gop senator from florida rick scott
discusses his party's chances
of sweeping the peach state what he
expects from a biden administration
and the hopeful news about covet 19
vaccines after recently testing positive
for the virus himself
amid a surge of coronavirus infections
across the nation
health officials are pleading with
americans to forgo travel
and large gatherings this holiday season
fox news headlines 24 7 reporter carly
schimketz shares insight
on how folks are making the best of
thanksgiving during these challenging
times
plus commentary from fox news
contributor pastor robert jeffress
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm tyrus i'm liz clayman i'm greg
jarrett
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday november 25th 2020 i'm lisa
brady
the president-elect says america is back
but some republicans in congress are
wondering
back to what i'm afraid that if we go
back to
policies like the obama policies we'll
be in the same position again where
where if you start out poor you don't
have much of a chance in this country
because
there's not there's not a lot of job
creation i'm chris foster
it's going to be a different kind of
thanksgiving for people taking
coronavirus precautions
that's what people love about
thanksgiving is you know sharing food
and
getting together and watching football
on the same couch and
the cdc uh guidelines do not want you to
do
any of that we speak with fox news
headlines 24 7 reporter carly shimkas
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
a day after president trump cleared the
way for a transition to officially begin
president-elect joe biden formally
introduced several
cabinet picks to the nation they'll tell
me what i need to know
not what i want to know what i need to
know
to the american people this team will
make us proud to be americans
it was a reintroduction for some
including former secretary of state and
presidential candidate john kerry
now in line to serve as a new
cabinet-level climate change
envoy even the united states for all of
our industrial strength
is responsible for only 13 percent of
global commissions
to end this crisis the whole world
must come together some of the nominees
would make history
the first woman to lead the intelligence
community the first latino
and immigrant head of homeland security
but enough former obama administration
officials
to draw criticism from both republicans
and progressive democrats
president trump still calls it a rigged
election tweeting that he's
fighting hard but he didn't mention the
ongoing legal challenges or take any
questions
during two white house appearances
tuesday including the annual turkey
pardon
on behalf of the entire trump family i
want to wish every american a healthy
and
very happy thanksgiving which followed
brief remarks on the dow
hitting thirty thousand for the first
time that's a sacred number thirty
thousand nobody thought they'd ever see
it
especially after dropping to nineteen
thousand in march
and the dow's new milestone was reached
as the u.s was crossing another covid
threshold 259 000 deaths
the president-elect has already
described the need for more coronavirus
relief
as urgent but a lame-duck congress
doesn't seem any more likely
to bridge the gap between the trillion
dollar packages passed by house
democrats
and the senate republican call for a
smaller targeted approach
well first off you know republican
senators have passed two
bills helping the people that have lost
their jobs
florida republican senator rick scott is
the new chairman of the senate gop's
campaign committee
we have extended ppp money to open
schools more money for testing more
money for vaccine
and unfortunately the democrat senators
have blocked it not one senator has
voted with us
so it's really completely being blocked
by uh democrat senators and what
i say what we're not going to do we're
not going to put up money to bail out
the pension plans of blue states i mean
it's not
i mean sort of taxpayers are not going
to pay for the pension plans of
california illinois or new jersey so i
think what
we're dealing with is the democrats will
have a bunch of liberal priorities that
they want and we want to do
a bunch of things to help americans and
the democrats are have no interest in
helping americans they just want their
liberal priorities
right and i mean that debate will
continue because from their
perspective they just keep saying well
especially speaker pelosi keeps saying
republicans
basically aren't willing to spend enough
to
crush the virus well to crush the
viruses
is testing um you know we
put up billions of dollars um for tests
we bought up the avid tests they're
being sent around the com around the
around the country
through the governor's offices the uh
the money we've sent the states for
testing has not been much of that has
not been used
so what's that saying is the democrats
just don't want to they just want
haters have a wish list and a lot of it
is they're just going to bail out states
and and when did the florida taxpayer
become responsible for
the illinois state pension plan i mean
it's
actually almost as simple as that
i wanted to ask how you're feeling
because you are one of several u.s
senators who tested positive for covid
just last week are you having any
symptoms
i'm fine it i my very mild uh case
or like a little bit of allergies or
slight cold
so i'm doing great um i look forward to
getting back up
to dc hopefully we we will um
be able to pass uh our you know our
budget
uh which has been frustrating to me that
we haven't passed the budget and
hopefully we can do it in a fiscally
responsible manner when i get back
as a republican are you relieved that
the president
has allowed essentially the transition
process to begin
well okay and we still need to make sure
all legal votes are cast we know
still need to the person still has the
right to go through
uh the legal you know questions he has
we still need to look for the fraud i
mean i think what's frustrating is the
american public
doesn't feel comfortable that this
election was fair uh i've got a bill
called the voter act which will actually
do mail-in ballot the way we do it
florida which has worked but you've
gotta you've gotta have signatures match
you've gotta
you can't have same-day registration
you've gotta have voter id you've gotta
do the things to make american
public feel safe about these elections
because if that's just gonna be this
election it'll be the next election when
when are we gonna start feeling uh
secure about our election system if we
don't
have a conversation and pass the bills
that are gonna make sure
we have national standards and locally
run elections
in terms of the president's legal
challenges over this election though
i mean at a certain point could it hurt
the republican party
for those challenges you know to
continue or just does that just become
less of a factor now that the transition
is getting underway
well i think it's all tied to when the
state certify and
so they're going through that process
the legal challenges will be heard i
went through this two years ago
i won handily by 54 000 votes election
night and chuck schumer sent a lawyer
down the next day and
he he's done he's not saying what donald
trump said donald trump says i want all
the legal votes counted
what chuck schumer's lawyer says i want
to win to the court systems i don't care
what the voters decided
so what what donald trump is doing is
exercising his legal right to make sure
all
votes legal votes are counted and make
sure there's no fraud
and so that's what we ought to be doing
but these states are going to be
certifying and
we'll know who um the the person is
going to be
i think pretty quickly i know that
carl bernstein of watergate fame wrote
recently about a number
of republican senators who he says have
expressed
extreme extreme contempt for the
president you know behind the scenes or
in conversations
but who also stayed silent about that
and helped enable
what he calls the president's most
grievous conduct
through their silence he puts you on
that list
what do you say about that view of the
president
and lawmakers who have supported him
it's ridiculous
and it's completely untrue is there
any concern that that reaches
voters that that affects you know the
long-term goal of
winning back the white house if the
president has lost it or even these
senate races in georgia that are coming
up in january the runoffs
well we're going to win the georgia
races and we're going to win because we
have very good candidates and we're on
the right side of the issue and
i think georgia voters realize that they
don't want chuck schumer
uh doing what he said he was going to
take georgia and then change the country
and he said we don't want
uh chuck schumer's plan for the country
he wants to pack the supreme court he
wants to infringe on our first amendment
rights our second amendment rights
he wants to eliminate uh
private health care coverage he wants to
ruin medicare
for the medicare recipients he wants the
green new deal which will cost almost
100 trillion dollars and kill our
economy
and as we know the democrats are not
into supporting law enforcement
so so i i'm very comfortable we're going
to win in georgia
because what we believe in is what
america believes in we
we believe in the chance to live the
dream of this country i'm a kid that
grew up in public housing
i want the chance to live the dream i
want every kid in this country to have
the same chance
that i had uh to be able to build a life
and go down the path that i wanted to go
down
i know you're head of the national
senatorial campaign committee now
do you have a sense that that message is
resonating in those georgia races or do
you have any concern about
turnout without president trump on the
ballot oh
there's people excited um i was down
there
i didn't i came in contact with somebody
after i came back to florida
so i uh i came down i went down to
georgia to uh
to campaign and we had a lot of
enthusiasm a lot of interest
we are working hard people have called
they want to go volunteer
they want to campaign they want to
give money they want to make sure that
that
we keep a republican senate so kelly
lesler and david perdue are great
candidates and we're going to have big
wins
the president-elect has gone ahead and
named some of his
cabinet picks and he's urging the senate
to give his nominees a fair chance
i hope these outstanding nominees
received a prompt hearing
and that we can work across the aisle in
good faith to move forward for the
country
do you expect a senate fight though over
any of those nominees or at least the
ones we know so far
well the first step is we've got to
certify the election uh
once that happens everybody will start
looking at um you know the
next president's uh picks here's here's
what's important to me
honesty integrity with regard to
fiscal responsibility they understand
that we have 27 trillion dollars for the
debt do they
understand that medicare is not funded
so security is not funded the federal
reserve is
out of control with the seven trillion
dollar budget do they
understand that we've got to stand up to
places like iran and communist china
they're clearly not our they're clearly
are our adversaries now
so i'm going to look at all these things
and when when i look at
any pics that come up from any president
assuming that biden is the next
president just for a moment
is there something that you'd be hoping
to work with him on
specifically for the american people
look i i ran for the first time in 2010
because i
believe in the dream of this country i
we need to create an economy
that we can create more jobs you do that
by lower taxes less regulation
uh let people leave their lives
unfortunately the democrats want to tell
you how to lead your lives instead of
let you go lead your life
and so i i want to build i want to build
this economy so
people have a better opportunity going
forward
as as we know under the obama years we
didn't have great growth
and i'm afraid that if we go back to
policies like the obama policies we'll
be in the same position again where
where if you start out poorer you don't
have much of a chance in this country
because
there's not there's not a lot of job
creation
and do you think that he'd be able to
sort of keep his moderate stance that he
took
um toward the latter part of the
campaign would he be able to keep that
as president and
try to work with both sides of the aisle
like he said he would do
i wouldn't work with anybody that's
going to help my state
so i've worked well with president trump
he understand the issues of florida i
know that joe biden doesn't know much
about florida
and the biggest thing we need is we need
a good economy and
joe biden has has no idea how to create
an economy what he
you look at is his uh his background is
he's he's big on taxes and he's big on
regulation
both of those things are going to be bad
for jobs
if he doesn't win a second term right
now would you like to see
president trump run again in 2024
absolutely i think i think uh president
trump
has worked his butt off i mean if you
look at if you look at the economy
before kovac if you look at if you look
at what he did in the middle east if you
look at his ability to hold
uh uh adversaries accountable if you
look at
its ability to get nato to put more
money up
for for the nato alliance i mean there's
a lot of great things
the president accomplished the
deregulation and absolutely
one last thing um to
maybe maybe end on a hopeful note um the
vaccines that appear to be just around
the corner
are you hopeful about the state
of the nation even though right now
there are so many
uh restrictions being reimposed
well first off i believe in mass i
believe in social distance
i believe if you're around somebody test
the possibly out of quarantine
i believe you ought to be test getting
tested to make sure that you don't make
anybody sick
um and i'm out i'm very optimistic about
the vaccine so i think i think that
that we've got to figure out how to open
our economy and i'm excited that the
vaccine is going to
uh is going to get people a lot of
safety
um and and help because i know we have
to open this economy but we got to do it
in a safe manner
senator rick scott get well soon happy
thanksgiving
thank you very much happy thanksgiving
it's gonna be a nice thanksgiving
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up thanksgiving's tomorrow
another tradition that's being changed
by the coronavirus pandemic this year at
least for families following the advice
of federal health officials like surgeon
general dr jerome adams
make sure you're setting up to uh to
maintain six feet of social distance
limiting
your number of guests ideally to less
than ten
and then ventilation outside is better
than inside and here in washington dc
it's actually going to be about 60
degrees warm enough to be outside
the centers for disease control is
advising people to not travel for the
holiday this year despite that advice a
lot of people like todd gross at the
dallas fort worth airport say they'll
take their chances
i'm not letting this hamper my lifestyle
in life you know family and friends are
more really important to me at this time
of the year
and he's not alone a lot of people have
chosen to do it despite
cdc guidelines carly shimkas is a
reporter for fox news headlines 24 7.
an estimated 50 million people are
expected to travel this year
it was 55 million last year so that's
you know pretty close to what happened
last year
the difference is that people are
choosing to travel mostly by
car so 95 of travel will likely be
vehicle travel this is according to aaa
2.4 million people will fly
which is a pretty sharp decline from 4.6
million
last thanksgiving so it seems like a lot
of people are going to be getting
together
but they are staying more local and
they're going to save those big
cross-country trips for next year what
they're saying what i'm learning about
airports is that it's not
the the flying that's so dodgy it's just
being
at the airport you're you're waiting
around in an enclosed space with a bunch
of people who may or may not be good
about wearing masks
it's the elevators it's the terminals
right yeah that's right
so um airlines have been very um open
and they've promoted the fact that they
have
hepa filtration systems so a lot of
doctors have even come out and said that
being on the airplane itself is
relatively safe
but the part that the cdc doesn't want
people to do is just congregate
in airports or really congregate at all
and of course
when you are traveling via air or car
that means that you are going to meet
other people and other family members
and friends and that's something that
the cdc does not particularly want
people to do this year
that's the travel now let's talk about
when you get where you're going
a lot of these recommendations seem
fairly
reasonable i guess keep your gathering
as low as possible i mean i guess the
really safest recommendation is to keep
it within your
you know so-called bubble but people are
obviously not doing that
the idea of getting together at
grandma's house and staying six feet
apart from everybody i don't know how
you grew up but
that's not that's not a possibility it
was knee to knee
at a table yeah and that's that you know
that's what thanksgiving that's what
people love about thanksgiving is
you know sharing food and getting
together and watching football on the
same couch and
the cdc uh guidelines do not want you to
do
any of that as a matter of fact they
recommend that people bring their own
food their own drinks their own plates
utensils so
they say no sharing this thanksgiving
and
they also suggest that masks should be
worn
when people aren't eating or drinking
and then of course there are the state
guidelines you know in new york
your governor cuomo has capped the limit
on thanksgiving to
10 people um in oregon that number is
capped at
six and that's where things have really
gotten controversial because you have
sheriffs who say
i'm not going to enforce those rules i'm
not going to you know knock on someone's
door and say you have 15 people in your
house five have to leave
and so then there's been this big back
and forth especially in new york with
governor cuomo saying
you know [ __ ] it's not the sheriff's
responsibility to choose
which laws he wants to enforce and which
ones that they don't
so that's where um things are getting
really sticky so with that said
i think the pandemic and its
restrictions will be on the minds of
a lot of people tomorrow a lot of zoom
meetings think this thanksgiving a lot
of face time
uh i guess that's another option zoom i
guess uh is actually
unlocking how many people you can have
at your gathering on thanksgiving day
yeah so you know if you can't meet in
person there is
there is always zoom um and zoom is
actually like you said yeah they're
letting
people use their service for free on
thanksgiving
usually for the free service you have a
40 minute limit so for
all of thursday they're removing that
they're letting people
get together on zoom for as long as they
choose
i've also seen a lot of other you know
sort of cute suggestions
uh how to make zoom thanksgivings a
little more personal
like you could play games over zoom or
even cook
meals over zoom and the idea is to cook
the same thing so you sort of feel like
you're together but you know of course
it is the it's it's a positive thing to
be in this digital world where we can
connect without being face to face
but it's not exactly the same thing now
tonight
is traditionally especially for um
maybe younger people a big big big night
for bars people come home from college
people
go back to their hometown from wherever
they move to and they see their old
buddies at the bars it's
one of the biggest drinking nights of
the year but that's not happening in a
lot of places
yes and it is specifically not happening
in pennsylvania
so governor tom wolf has said that
starting at 5 p.m um tonight
bars and restaurants have to stop
serving alcohol
because you know the eve of thanksgiving
is a big one
for gathering especially from younger
people that are
coming home from college they tend to
all get together
on thanksgiving eve and the governor
wants to stop
that from happening now unfortunately
for bars and restaurants who are already
struggling under you know the crippling
economic ramifications of all these
coronavirus lockdowns they are
you know hurting even more because of
this um
and a lot of uh especially in
philadelphia you know indoor dining is
already
um is already no longer allowed
so restaurants in bars in philadelphia
are saying you know
this is this is hurting us to no end
uh one of the perks of working at fox is
the thanksgiving day parade if you're
working that day or even if you're not
some people come in on their day off and
you can watch the parade from inside of
our building
or from or from some of the windows
that's
going to be a little different this year
yeah that's right and you
are correct that is a big perk of
working
in the fox news building so uh the good
news is that the parade is
sort of happening uh the not so great
news is that it is going to look very
different this year
they have scrapped the 2.5 mile parade
route
uh they've also scaled back on
performances and the number of
participants
it's really going to be a very um tv
focused event meaning it's going to be
pre-produced filmed recorded throughout
this week the rock cats will still be
performing
in some of the most popular balloons
like you know the snoopy balloon
elf on the shelf um the pillsbury
doughboy boy they'll be in the
tv event but you know i commend them for
trying to put this on and giving people
something exciting to watch
uh tomorrow morning uh just for a minute
though and then
you have to turn back to fox news of
course if the rock hats
are part of anybody's tradition or if
anybody ever thought about maybe coming
to new york to watch the show you
obviously can't do it this year uh but
the rock hats i've noticed are actually
doing
uh free performances and free dance
classes
online so you can take you can do that
if you know that
wow can i just say um last christmas
i went over to radio city music hall for
a fox and friends piece
and the rockettes tried to teach me how
to kick
and i failed miserably so
kicking and stretching in any sort of
capacity
not my forte you're also too tall yeah
that's really the thing that's really
the thing
you have to be between whatever height
and whatever height to be a rock hat in
your room
above it the holidays are tough for a
lot of people every
year who may just
be lonely or just to have uncomfortable
family situations it's going to be extra
tough this year for people that have
been isolated for a long time maybe a
suggestion carly
give a call to and whoever or your
grandma
maybe everybody should try that tomorrow
yeah i am so glad that you brought that
up because
i have been hearing a lot of doctors on
tv
talking about how even under normal
circumstances november and december
can be tough for some people um to deal
with
you know loneliness depression sets in
for a lot of folks this time of year and
that
um is made even you know highlighted
even more given the fact that a lot of
people throughout this year
have been separated and isolated so
absolutely you know
um give a phone call you know for
christmas
mail the card uh take that couple
moments out of your day to make folks
even if you don't talk to them
every single day or you know this would
be the time
to to make them feel special because you
never know what people are going through
what a lot of people are going through
is a lot of food insecurity
there are food lines around
blocks in some cases um people are
usually pretty charitable with food
stuff around thanksgiving but that's an
ongoing situation right now i had a
friend who
was complaining about his commute one
day oh my god there's all this traffic
he felt terrible later when he found out
that that traffic was
two miles of cars waiting to get into a
civic center to get boxes of food
people that never had these problems
before you know that actually reminds me
of
something that tyler perry did in
atlanta he helped a bunch of
and i mean a lot of families um he
his production company handed out a
bunch of free food boxes and gift cards
and he funded the whole entire thing
himself and he fed 5 000 families
and people waited in line for almost a
full day
there was one woman who waited in line
for 18 hours and she called it a true
blessing
um but as with every year you
can you know donate to your local food
bank your church
uh a lot of churches do great work of
course this time of year you know
feeding america also does some fantastic
stuff
yeah all right so those of us who are
thankful enough to be uh
still employed and everything's going
relatively well through all this maybe
uh dig a little bit deeper this year
carly
what are you doing for thanksgiving
what's your plans oh okay so i will be
uh working throughout the uh week
but on saturday i will be cooking my
very first turkey
and i have low expectations for success
similar to my rockette skills i expect
failure
but i'm gonna try anyway i have faith
you can do it
um carly shimkas you can see her on fox
news channel
fox business network you can hear on uh
fox news headlines 24 7 on siriusxm
carly it was uh
good to talk to you misha i miss you too
i can't wait to see you
give you a hug when you come back happy
thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind in october of 1789
george washington issued our nation's
first thanksgiving proclamation
declaring that thursday november 26
would be quoted
devoted by the people of these states to
the service of that great and glorious
being
who is the beneficent author of all the
good that was
that is or that will be washington was
just a few months into his first term
it was far from clear that our fledgling
nation
would survive much less be thriving over
200 years later
yet washington found much to be thankful
for
he called upon americans to be united in
rendering unto god
our sincere and humble thanks for what
we had
washington recounted how god's provision
had been evident throughout the history
of the nation
from settling the colonies to making it
through a difficult war
the nation's statesmen had come to a
peaceable
ratification of the new constitution
americans lived in a land with civil and
religious liberty the new president
was grateful washington also called on
the nation
to unite in most humbly offering our
prayers and supplications
to the great lord and ruler of nations
and beseech him to pardon our
national and other transgressions
from the outset our nation has aspired
to be great
but it hasn't ever been perfect
washington encouraged all americans to
acknowledge this
they were invited to spend thanksgiving
not only in gratitude
but in repentance as well these
responses
gratitude and repentance don't come
naturally to us
americans have always been a
hard-working industrious people
we're proud of what we make and what we
accomplish
we're always striving for more planning
for the next quarter
projecting growth into the future we've
got a natural dissatisfaction
with the status quo thanksgiving however
is a way americans devised in our
earliest days
to collectively hit pause on the grind
and toil of work
instead of being hyper focused on what
we can achieve
we take a day off to look at all the
things god
has achieved for us when you look back
at the past few decades
we seem to have so much more now than
we've ever had
yet i think we enjoy it much less this
has been going on since well before the
pandemic
we experienced incredible economic
growth
alongside sky rocketing depression
loneliness
and addiction across our nation our
growing dissatisfaction with life
is because of our nation's shrinking
belief in god
a fact that is verified by numerous
public opinion polls
but thanksgiving as a holiday makes no
sense
and serves no purpose without god you
can't be
thankful unless you're thankful to
someone
you can't see what you have as a gift
unless you admit you received it
from someone i'm praying that amidst all
the challenges we face this year as a
nation
we might return back to that spirit
expressed by our first
president at the first national
thanksgiving
back in 1789 let's not spend the day
simply overeating and hunting for black
friday deals
on our iphones let's set aside sometime
on thursday
to give thanks to the lord for his
steadfast love
which endures throughout pandemics and
political turmoil
and into all eternity this is robert
jeffress
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes